فاعصيله قتلى الجيش التركي قد تدفع بانقره
شيئا فشيئا باتجاه العمل البري باعتبار
انها تقول انها تواجه تهديدا حقيقيا
وارتفاع حصيله القتلى لدى الجنود الاتراك
والمدنيين وايضا قوات الامن في المنطقه
الحدوديه هو دليل على ان هذه المنطقه
الحدوديه تشكل تهديدا كبيرا لانقره
وبالتالي التحرك ميدانيا بريا باتجاه
النقاط المحدده
للتوغل البري منبج تل رفعت واا كوباني
الليله الماضيه وكانت همم فيها القارات
الجويه هي الاعلى في انها جاءت ردا على
مقتل اثنين من الجنود الاتراك في هجوم
اليها المسلحين هذا الاكراد بيان وزاره
الدفاع التركيه التي قالت انها تمكنت من
تحيده 22 مسلحا في العراق وسوريا خلال
الغارات الجويه ولكن العمليه البريه بحسب
التصريحات
قادمه لكن التوقيت لم يحدد بعد ربما اليوم
همم ربما غدا ولكن اذا ما شلنا التركيه
العمليه البريه فقد لا تجد اا اكثر من
اليوم مناسبه لهذا التوغل البري لماذا
لانه يصادف الذكر الرابعه والاربعين
لتاسيس حزب العمال الكردستاني عامه 78
وبالتالي التحرك همم في هذا اليوم هو ضربه
معنويه اضافه الى انه رساله الى الداخل
التركي همم الرئيس اردوغان وحزب العداله
والتنميه يقيمون اليوم تجمعا كبيرا في
اسطنبول اذا ما اراد اردوغان ان يقول شيئا
اذا ما اراد ان يعلن حدثا كبيرا ربما
اليوم هو اليوم المناسب ولكن بطبيعه الحال
العمليه العسكريه تحتاج الى اتخاذ قرار
القرار همم يجنب الجيش التركي الخسائر
المحتمله من المواجهه البريه مع قوات
الكرديه لذلك تركيز حتى الان الغارات
الجويه العنيفه والقذف المدفعي على مواقع
ودفاعات المقاتلين الاكراد في هذه المناطق
الرئيسيه كوباني ومنبج ومنه وتل رفعت
لتمهيد الطريق امام التوغل البري الذي
بطبيعه الحال بدا فسيبدا بعناصر المعارضه
المسلحه التي تلقت التعليمات فع